hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast optimization of new
series transient expression platforms
presented by Christine according
scientists of protein sciences I can see
be fun I'm Suzy Valdez and I will be
your moderator for this educational
webcast presented by the labyrinth and
sponsored by Fisher Scientific before we
begin I'd like to find everyone we urge
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
this presentation just click on the
green Q&A button and type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
once er as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
giving this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing whose
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right or please turn
me now and welcome Christine yeah I know
every
and soothe thank you very much for the
kind introduction in the next 20 to 30
minutes I'm going to talk to talk about
the optimization of UCB strands and
expression platforms so I'm going to
introduce you to UCB to our transient
expression platforms at UCB - the
improvements that we made to our large
scale transit expression platforms
include friends that we made to our
small scale transit expression platform
and our plans for automation so UCB is a
global biopharma company and our vision
is to meet our patients unmet needs and
we're focused on severe diseases into
therapeutic areas naming neurology and
immunology we have over 1,000 employees
within UCB RMD spread over to research
centers and based in Slough and if you
look at the top left corner and the
middle one those are our sites in Slough
and then in Brennan Belgium which you
can see at the bottom right corner you
should be spends 27% of its revenues
within R&D which really shows how
researched or than we are so here I
wanted to show you our folic and
exciting UCB pipeline so throughout the
project progression you can see that
we've got quite a number of exploratory
targets
ten to 20 in the early stages then we
have our early stage projects about 15
to 25 but any one time through to the
preclinical phase and then in our
clinical places we've got quite a number
of Neurology projects here seen in beds
and immunology projects Yaseen include
and what I wanted to show you here is
that we have quite a number of projects
and they all will need to be supported
by a large number of reagents during
that progression this is why I wanted to
also show you a typical project
progression and the reagents that are
required to support the drug discovery
process
development and during that time there
are large numbers of reagents required
as you can see here in the early stages
through the identification large panels
of antibodies and antigens are required
its small amounts and then going through
to the clinical development the number
of antibodies required decreases but we
need larger amounts of those to support
all the various studies at any one stage
and we typically would provide these
reagents through a transient protein
production which takes us about two two
weeks eight weeks through to the
preclinical phase from the DNA to the
pre-fight protein and from then onwards
was a slight over that it's the stable
seven generation that kicks in which
takes about three to five months from
the DNA to protein and all of this
really shows that there is a clear need
for flexible and efficient transient
expression platforms to fully support
pipeline so here I just wanted to show
you a range of 1990 formats that are
tend to be required and the choice
forward is usually driven by the
therapeutic needs and in the past we've
mainly been asked to express your
standard antibodies like your IgG which
tend to be easier to express but more
recently we've been asked to express by
specific formats and other antibody
formats which tend to be more difficult
to express so this really shows that our
expression platforms need to be really
capable to support all the needs so here
I'm going to show you the expression
platforms that we have available from
the medium to larger scale and one of
them is our in-house an extra creature
you can see a picture here on the side
so the typical process would be that you
take yourself
wash them in buffer concentrate them at
your DNA you only quote them out into
the Corvette's and you can
see one of these bullets and the cadet
holder in the picture and you like to
create yourself and then you transfer it
into your production media this is a
fairly efficient methods that we have
and we typically using this between 200
meter scale it takes 4 milligram DNA per
meter transaction the 14 about 14 day
process and was seen quite high yields
of around 200 to 1000 milligrams per
liter antibody the slight downside of
this method is that it becomes really
labor-intensive if you do transactions
above the 5 liter scared because
attending to expression for example
would take a hundred and twenty commits
for this reason we bought in the MaxLite
large gets low a little greater which
you can see in the picture here so
rotated to expression dis electroporator
would take about half an hour so the way
this works is that you again take
yourself you watch the member
concentrate them at your DNA and there
are connected in machine the
electroporator would then pump the cells
through the electroporation so chamber
which you can see in the middle it's
like the orange and it will connect the
electric rates it cells on the site
waiting to be transfer it into your
production medium for culturing and this
method we typically use above the 5
liter scale and we again need four
milligrams of DNA penny touch inspection
it takes the same amount of time 10 to
14 days and due to intensive
optimization that has run into this
system we are also able to achieve
around two hundred to a thousand
milligrams per liter our antibody so now
I wanted to show you some of the story
improvements that we made to our large
scale platform we've been continuously
optimizing this platform over the years
and about 10 to 15 years ago we started
to develop the platform and we found
that it shows suspension host
electroporation and attempt shift
applied adding as fresh expression
enhancers would give us the highest
yields throughout the years we started
to do hosts and host online engineering
and we developed our show where succeed
cell line which over expresses XB p1
which was a large dr and arrow one alpha
which aids disulfide bond formation and
thereby we are most of the time seeing
up to a five-fold increase in expression
levels and moving on through the years
we also look continuously at optimizing
our media and processes and here is one
example where we looked at different
commercially available media and in our
case perch of five has given us the
highest yields and another example here
is that we develop defect batch process
for our show and expiration process and
this vet batch process has given has
doubled basically other eels overall
standard process so some of the more
recent improvements that we made to our
large scale platform is that we
revisited the media additives and feeds
again and we found a new production
media that would give us about one and a
half fold increase over our current
media and previously we have been using
sodium glutamate as an expression
enhancer but we found a recent paper
that states that malaria yes it can
improve recommend recommend and antibody
production and we tested this and they
found that when we're using Balearic
acid in our system we can see up to a
1/4 increase in expression levels which
is great and then finally we also
optimized our feeling strategy and by
doing so
[Music]
so when we look at the impact that these
improvements had on our large-scale
expression system you can see this graph
here that shows the amount of antibody
expressed over the past three years and
if you look at 2013 where we expressed
about 40 grams we are in 2016
drastically up at about 140 grams which
is a drastic improvement over the years
for now moving on to our small scale
systems throughout the years we've seen
a large increase in the number of
small-scale in transactions and we
believe that even more will be required
in the future so this graph is actually
an example where you can see that in
2013 the transactions performed that
were below 30 mils are quite no and then
from 2014 onwards there is a high
inertia increase in the numbers of
small-scale transactions in a 30 mil so
therefore we felt that we need to
increase the throughput of our
small-scale expression system and there
is definitely scope for improvement
our aim was to develop a high throughput
small-scale expression platform and for
that we wanted to have a look at at the
host again find an optimal one see which
translation method is the most suitable
one find a suitable culture vessel and
also try to improve our clarification
method so now I just wanted to quickly
tell you which transit expression
platforms we are using currently for our
small-scale arm systems so one of them
is duration based system called xb2
they're three supplied by thermo Fisher
I just wanted to quickly show you what
the process is so you take your starts
they load them in XP - that's remedial
you take your DNA and you
a reagent and diluted in optimum you add
them together incubators for 20 minutes
before you're adding it to your
transaction culture and after about 60
to 18 hours you would add your enhancers
and this is quite efficient system which
we mainly use a small snare and around
500 mil up to like about 200 Moscow
mainly but we have been able to push it
up to the 10 meter scale quite
successfully as well it takes less DNA
only one milligram DNA per liter
transaction it is also a shorter process
of about 7 to 10 days but it gives us
slightly lower yields in comparison to
other systems only 10 to 600 milligrams
per liter antibody we also have another
system a reagent plate system that we
use mania small scale also supplied by
thermal Fisher's called X speed show
it's very similar the process is very
similar to the XP to nitrous system so
here again you dilute your cells to
about 6 million cells per milliliter and
you take your DNA and your reagent and
dilute it in the medium called optic
probe you mix them together and quite
straight afterwards you add it to your
transaction culture on day 1 you have
the option of using the temperature to
32 degrees and to add seeds and then
there's another option to add more feeds
on day 5 but a system we mainly use it
about the three hundred milliliter
onwards mark has been able in a few
occasions to test it up to this 10 meter
scale it takes also only 1 milligram DNA
per liter transcription process very
similar to our child education methods
10 to 14 days but we've seen higher
yields here as well we've seen between
200 up to a thousand milligrams per
liter antibody but if we're moving on
now to finding the optimal host for our
health preferred approach we compare
yields of shows and patron countries at
small scale and here you can see that by
consistently the cho cells would give us
higher yields which is why we decided to
move on with our show
align those we're looking at the
selection of the optimal transaction
method you have two methods available at
the moment it's our show at expiration
and at show we agent-based both of these
giving us fairly high yields so the
question was on how so easy to automate
and we considered quite a few different
options regarding me an expiration
method but we felt that for now it
wasn't really suitable for an automated
- approach so we wanted to see whether
the reagent based system would live up
to this so so to test this we felt that
we already have the my 15 in-house it's
an automated liquid handling and
culturing system so we wanted to program
this automation system to do the
transaction makes preparation of the
culturing for us so here's an example
experiment where you have your shake +
control on the side as you see in purple
and then we have programmed the amber to
do the transaction mix preparation for
you and with its liquid handling
capabilities and then we took the
prepared transaction mix off the amber
and edited to shape flask cultures and
incubated it in the incubator as you can
see here the six identical inspections
they're the Easter for improvement but
they're not too far of our shake bus
control so now we did it the other way
around
we prepared the transaction makes
manually in the hood as we would usually
do and then added it to the automation
unit the culturing unit of the amber and
as you can see here there is a benefit
over doing so and then finally we
actually program the amber to do the
whole job for us and as you can see here
in most of the cases if not all the
yields are good better if not better
than our shake so this made us feel very
confident that the invasion based method
is the one to go forward with
they're now looking at a selection of an
optimal cultural vessel and we felt like
the amber 15 is an automated system but
it isn't high throughput enough for us
and also the 10 milliliter scale is not
quite sufficient enough so we were
looking at something around 30 to 50 mil
and but we spring the market and try to
find an optimal culture vessel and we
found that spin cubes our idea for this
Heights with that approach because they
require less incubator space and they're
also easier to automate because there
are already devices out there on the
market that can handle these tattoos and
to test this again we bought in spin
tubes from three different suppliers use
of a B and C and we compared these to
our shake and as you can see all of
these spin ships bond really well in
comparison to the shape lost and we felt
like we wanted to move on with the spin
tube supplier a so finally I wanted to
we wanted to improve our clarification
method and to do so we compared it to
standard versus a new method developed
by satorious and if we look at our
standard methods where we centrifuge our
sample for at least 30 minutes
high-speed an unsterile filter it's
reserved what should my stellar filter
be kind often find that approaches would
look and several photos would be needed
to verify the sample so here we have one
example where it took a one liter
culture divided it in half and 500 mil I
centrifuged
and added the supernatant to a bottle
closure and you can see that after about
a hundred mils the bottle top filter
blocked and nothing was going through
anymore so if we look at the de
classification method in comparison
there's no centrifugation meters and for
example you would throw up your saw
suspension into a syringe those already
prefilled
the diatomaceous earth you gently mix it
and then you push it through 0-2
micrometer Star reporter and this is
really easy
most often does not result in any
blockage and this is also the reason why
it would be more suitable for automation
so I've got the tire comparison here so
the other half of the culture I took and
added the GE to it mix it gently and
then added it culture straight and as
you can see here so I just added some
pictures as well of a smaller scale
approach using te so here you have here
a prefilled syringe with te you to roll
up your cell suspension from your
culture vessel you mix the syringe
slightly and then you add your stirrer
filter to the top of the syringe you can
just push it supernatant so for these
reasons we felt like the de
clarification method is definitely more
suitable for a high throughput
automation approach so now coming back
to our initial plans for increasing the
throughput of our small-scale expression
system we found that the cho cell line
would be most suitable that reagent
based method is suitable for this
approach and that spring troops would be
idea
we also found an improved clarification
method so the next step would be to put
all of this into automation so our
future transient automation platform
we're imagining to be a modular system
where you have a transient expression
module which can do your preparation of
your transmission mixture will do your
DNA calculations and dilutions it can do
the addition of yourself the feed
additions the cell count by an
integrated cell counter they would do
samplings something for essays and all
of this culture scale of between 20 and
40 millimeters so we have a module
supporting this transient module would
be the DNA preparation
modification module which we imagine to
be automated than this suspension
preparation which at the moment is were
imagined to be manual stir then there
needs to be a user interface where you
can mediate feeds and samples for
analysis then you would have the
interactions with your incubators that
could be either manual or automated and
finally also a clarification module
module which we imagined to be a de
based method so just on summary I've
shown you the ever increasing demand for
proteins to support the unity pipeline
I've shown you the continuous
improvements that were made to our
transient expression platforms I've
shown you our robust and high expression
pressing show system for large scale and
our high expressing and high throughput
system for small scale and the next
steps would be for us to increase
automation to increase the small scale
delivery so I would like to thank the
protein science team at UCB especially
Bernie Sweeney some hey worked on a
highly on Cassie crane I'm very happy to
answer any questions thank you very much
now start with our live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the create a Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
start with our first question from our
audience members Christina you mentioned
that there has been a large increase in
the number of small-scale transactions
in the past few years with the
prediction of further increase in the
future how are you going to ensure that
the automation system
yeah thank you very much that's a great
question um we have decided that we
wanted to keep this automation platform
as simple as possible so we wanted to
just focus on the capacity rather than
focus on how many different things it
can do how many different scales and so
on so if we keep it simple and say it
can do consistently 30 Mills all the
time and if we ever heard a demand for
example of expressing 200 bills then we
would just do several times 30 knots so
we wanted it to be as high throughput as
possible but fairly simple so hopefully
that will work in your top you also
mentioned that you are using books the
XP 293 and XP Cho reagent based systems
as small scale the XP Cho system seems
to achieve generally high yields under
which circumstances would you still use
the XP 293 system over the XP Cho system
yes thank you for our question um so the
XP 293 system is still a great system
because especially when there is time
pressure it has a shorter process
shorter time so it's only seven to ten
days so we would definitely use it when
were under time pressure and the other
thing is translational modifications so
sometimes there's an advantage of using
human sods over cho cells and yeah so we
found that not every antibody or express
as well so sometimes we just because
some in the okay so the just just wanted
to explain what do you eat is it just in
tract your cells within the de structure
and would still keep it porous so that
you wouldn't receive any filter blockage
so when you're using de 0.2 micrometer
filter would be sufficient with that but
you need to filter that has a little bit
of dead space on top
because there will be a photo cake that
is made out of de and nor yourselves and
your Debra thank you so much if there
are no further questions
today yeah thank you very much for this
opportunity I really enjoyed it and I'm
very thankful that I got the opportunity
to present here in this forum well thank
you very much Christine I'd like to also
think and scientific educational
webcasts possible additional questions
will be answered and published on Thermo
Fisher Scientific sweb site you will
receive an email notification what
answers are available before we go I
want everyone to know that today's
webcast is available on-demand viewing
until August 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting me know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events about twenty five
minutes to take a break
stretch your feet so our next fabulous
presenter begins thanks so much for
joining us at this virtual conference we
hope to see you again good bye